[Music]
this edible money is a symbolic treat
in some parts of the world chocolate
coins are stuffed in christmas stockings
to celebrate the charity of saint
nicholas
they're also handed out to jewish
children during the festival of hanukkah
to teach them the value of money and
charity
chocolate coins don't have any
purchasing power but they do buy a lot
of appreciative smiles from the kids
[Music]
they start with giant chocolate bars
each one is 10 pounds of pure chocolate
the worker transfers the big bars to a
kettle it's a kind of double boiler hot
water bubbles and steams inside a sleeve
shell to heat and melt the chocolate
there are two and a half tons of liquid
chocolate in this kettle
the machine now pumps the chocolate
through a long pipe with different
cooling zones the chocolate thickens but
not to the point of solidification a
process called tempering
it causes the chocolate to form a
precise crystal structure for just the
right texture and taste
the thick liquid chocolate flows onto a
conveyor that brings the chocolate under
a broad blade
[Music]
the blade levels it to a specific
thickness and spreads it evenly creating
a long sheet of chocolate the chocolate
now begins to coagulate and harden
to spur that process it travels through
a refrigeration tunnel that is
approximately 15 yards long
this journey transforms the liquid
chocolate into a soft solid
next they clean and prepare the die
it's a spring-loaded device that works
cookie cutter style to punch out round
blanks
there is one big difference
each cutter is long and tubular so as it
punches out the chocolate blanks they
accumulate inside
[Music]
the lattice work of leftovers journeys
forward to be re-melted into the process
so not a crumb of chocolate goes to
waste
at the end of the line dozens of coin
blanks have stacked up in each magazine
and piles of leftover chocolate have
accumulated in a bin that will now be
transferred back to the melting pot
now it's time to print some chocolate
money to do this they wrap the chocolate
first and then emboss both the wrap and
the chocolate blank simultaneously
here's how it works sheets of glossy
gold foil travel between rollers to
establish an even tension ahead a forked
arm moves two chocolate blanks between
the foil sheets piston-like knives move
in to wrap cut and fold the foil around
the blanks the forked arm then delivers
the foil wrapped blanks to a die press
it stamps designs on both sides of the
coins making an impression on the foil
through to the chocolate
the chocolate although solid is still
warm enough to receive the image
removed from the machine here's what the
die heads look like
these are used to emboss chocolate coins
with american penny markings
as for the foil discards they don't end
up on the scrap heap instead they
accumulate in a bin to be sent out for
recycling
they make 150 000 foil wrapped coins a
day
[Music]
to change the currency type they simply
switch die heads
chocolate coins can be made in many
sizes with a range of different
illustrations
the coins now spill out onto a conveyor
that takes them to a bin
all that's left now is the packaging
which will be the traditional mesh bag
from start to finish it takes less than
an hour to make a chocolate coin
gold dollars or five dollar poker chips
every day it's a jackpot of chocolate
money at this factory so there's never
any shortage of edible cash only
decisions to be made poker chip or
chocolate penny you could always flip a
coin
[Music]
you